I don't know if you remember or not that
article came out talking about the fact
that uh you know how Bitcoin uh matches
I don't remember the exact number 74 of
the time uh it was not sorry it was 74
of the last 90 days every time the
market went up Bitcoin went up every
time the market went down Bitcoin went
down I don't know if you remember this
or not it's an article that came out
probably you know nine months ago eight
months ago even around the time that we
sat down together it tracked the
correlation between Bitcoin and the
stock very very close very each other
right but now Dao went all the way down
to 28 okay s p went down to I want to
say 3 300 I don't know the exact number
I'll say 33 something maybe even 3280
give or take and then Dow's up right now
how much is that can you look at what S
P 500 is at right now I don't know what
the exactly now is at 33.9 by the end of
the day SMP is 4080. now three thirty
nine thirty nine okay perfect so what if
you look at the rolling 12 lowest was
what 52 week low 34.91 okay so 34.91 but
if you look at Bitcoin go on bitcoin at
the same time and let's look at what
bitcoin's at uh uh Bitcoin Bitcoin is
currently at 16. okay but if you go high
high is what for the year I want to say
50 rolling 12. go one year go one year
one year one year right there no that's
one month go to one year one year is
that what 50 something uh if you go all
the way at the top go all the way at the
top 50 something so
um
gold they would say if you print money
gold will go up inflation goes up gold
will go up right Bitcoin was matching
the market now it's not matching the
market at least it was matched in the
market when the market was going up now
the market went up and if you look at
this it's flatlining and going lower and
lower slightly right if you look at
every time it comes down pumps Spike up
everything comes out boom Spike up comes
down boom Skype Spike up
today Draper comes out and says by the
end of next year you know Bitcoin is
going to go up to you know 250
000 I think he said that earlier today
but at the same time he was supportive
of Elizabeth Holmes till the very end so
you know when you look at some of this
stuff and you compare them with the
numbers that you see
why why isn't Bitcoin no longer
responding to the market the way it was
before and now it's kind of the
correlation is no longer the same what
do you think is the cause of that
I mean Bitcoin goes through phases where
it's either positively correlated to
risk assets or is negatively correlated
or it's uncorrelated and it all comes
down to the the microdynamics like how
are all the exchanges and all the other
crypto Traders how are they behaving and
then the macro Traders how are the macro
Traders perceiving it and that's
continually evolving let me uh let me
give you one interesting stat you know
like on August 10th microstrategy
decided to get into this business so
August 10 2020. so if you go back to the
summer of 2020 when it was it was just
unclear what are all these assets going
to do you said August 10th August 10th
so I I track this because this is my
scorecard because on August 11th we
announced we bought a quarter billion
dollars worth of bitcoin and we've been
long Bitcoin ever since
if you had taken a billion dollars and
you had bought bonds like long bonds
20-year Bonds in the summer of 2020 and
held them through today you would be
down 19 8 to 10 19 the bond index is
minus 19. billion dollars will be 810
million dollars yeah if you bought gold
you'd be down 13 okay if you had bought
the NASDAQ
you would be up three percent
it pretty much chopped sure right if you
bought the s p index you would be up 19
not not bad not bad sure not bad if you
bought Bitcoin you'd be up 43 Bitcoin
doubled the performance of those other
assets even as it got beat around the
ears and if you had gone into big Tech
and you bought Google you'd be up 34 not
as good as Bitcoin but better than
NASDAQ Apple's up 30 Microsoft is up 19
about 20 so those three are monopolies
the three most powerful Tech monopolies
in the world but Netflix down 34 Amazon
down 42 and facebook slash meta down 54
and that's why NASDAQ chopped sideways
now what is the what is the point well
Bitcoin is really volatile no doubt
about it it's hair on fire but if you
and if you're gonna be an investor for
less than 12 months you were just a
Speculator and you're a Trader and God
bless you if you go short you make some
money if you pick it right but if you
pick wrong get your face ripped off and
I don't know how to do that I mean you
have to be a Trader but if your time
Horizon is four years two years four
years eight years Beyond and if you're
buying it as a long-term store of value
Asset and you're just are you disgusted
with the manipulation of the fiat
currency
then you buy Bitcoin because you're
angry that they keep printing more pesos
and boulevards and dollars and Euros are
you disgusted that the CEO of your
favorite company screwed you by making
bad decisions I won't name the company
fill in your own
then you're going to buy Bitcoin there's
no CEO Bitcoin are you you know so if
you if you want to escape
that uh that particular risk and what
you want to do is you don't want to
trust a CEO a company a government or
anybody and if you want to buy something
that you can hold for 30 years
well I can tell you I can't pick a
single company that I would want to hold
30 years I can't you know there's not a
piece of land I would hold for 30 years
because I don't know that the mayor
wouldn't
you know the guy that replaces the mayor
next might decide to Triple the property
tax
and you know so there are a lot of
things in this world that are just very
risky
Bitcoin fits in a portfolio and it's
performing just fine as long as you have
a a two-year plus time Horizon and if
you have a short time Horizon if you
want to look at 12 weeks 18 weeks one
year
every single investment in the last 12
months looks pretty hideous and I can
probably tell you that you know if you
lost 20 percent of your money you're a
fool if you lost 40 percent you feel
like a bigger fool if you lost 60 you
feel like a bigger full so
Real Estate Investors Securities
investors Bond investors crypto
investors Bitcoin investors there's no
winners or your future looks bright hat
click over here and to watch the entire
podcast click here take care everybody
[Music]